all
women are great women get yourself one
pandemic taught me ain't no wrong one
all women is the right one get yourself
one
get yourself a big girl if you got a
choice
you need a big girl I was in the
pandemic I tried I saw I conquered I
felt it I know if you want to go through
a pandemic get you a big woman it'll be
the easiest pandemic you ever you can
trust a big woman you don't even know
you already know you hungry and she
already cooking
your stomach hurt S I think she got it
big woman is perfect in the pandemic she
do everything right
if it's cold she'll heat up the whole
room
cracking her legs one time
it was too hot she won't even touch your
Skin's skin she don't want it to stick
fellas you get with a big girl you'll
feel your body do some [ __ ] you ain't
never felt your body do and your body
ain't never been trained to do
all you need to do is get a big enough
girl and you'll feel your body Nestle
look at [ __ ] what
if you ever roll over on a woman bigger
than you you did
[Applause]
it's the safest sleep you ever gonna
have that's what I'm saying
yes
all the women is exciting I got me a
short girl I've never had a short girl
before because I'm short
[ __ ] what I'd be doing with somebody
short but I was missing out I didn't
know there was that much fun I [ __ ]
the short girl in the car this [ __ ] was
in every chair in the car and me and my
dick never moved
she was just about
I like a giant girl
no disrespect to the tall girls
I don't mean five nine five twelve none
of that
I'm to my six four six five uh
I'm about a giant woman
how big you wanna get a giant
I want them so big if she cooking
breakfast in the kitchen
and one of them summer dresses I won't
be able to slide up right between the
vagina without breaking the Strand
[Applause]
grab that clitoris like a red nose pit
I like a woman so big you got a [ __ ] her
in two rooms
this one you got one mwnba girls
you [ __ ] her in two rooms
I'm in the bedroom locked in for damage
[Applause]
every 150 Strokes I go check on it in
the living room
[Applause]
delivery
[Applause]
just saying I like it
I like all the girls
I ain't got no favorites
did I say this
some women don't get their flowers at
all
it's a group of women around the whole
world and nobody ever talks about
and they keep everything going and
they'll never get no credit we're gonna
talk about them and give them their
credit tonight
where's all the fellas in here where the
ugly woman make some noise
[Applause]
some people saw their whole marriage go
before they act
[Applause]
look
oh everybody in there with somebody ugly
know better they just staring at me like
this
now
you supposed to want what you need
you both want what you need
when you was in the bathroom crying to
the Lord
you said send me the [ __ ] I need
that is the [ __ ] you need
yeah
yeah stop judging people
by the outside only [ __ ] you me
the ugliest people be pretty
they still ugly
every man in here with ugly woman know
something the world don't know
she might be ugly to you
she ain't ugly to me
I ain't gonna tell you why
but sometimes you need an ugly woman
ugly woman will save your [ __ ]
life
you can be famous being okay
all of us know the story of Harriet
Tubman
they don't tell us but two things about
Harriet
they tell us
that she freed the slaves
and
she was ugly
you [ __ ]
it's the truth
that's what the [ __ ] they say she freed
the slaves
and
she was up
it's a [ __ ] lie
Harriet
was [ __ ] beautiful
slavery was
ugly [ __ ]
one more time for the people in the back
I say
[Applause]
look
uh-huh uh-huh
and the freedom slaves
Harriet needed to be ugly
cause the enemy was ugly
Harriet wasn't the only woman out there
freeing slaves
there was another woman out there
praying slaves her name was Beulah
she was beautiful looked like Tracy
Ellis Ross light-skinned hair down to
her ass bubble butt smell like fruit and
berries everybody loved them
thousands of slaves followed Beulah
but beautiful could get you away from
being a slave you need it ugly
cause your life was on the line [ __ ]
this real slavery
you in the real woods
it's really midnight
and if anybody see you
from an adult to a small child
your ass is dead [ __ ]
and you going through that movie
you hear them dogs coming from a
distance yeah
and that's generally when [ __ ] get
scared start running they get killed
but you ain't had to be scared if you
was with Harry
them dogs are coming
with them dogs
pull a pistol out of my panties but you
just hit it all
[Applause]
right
a lot of people follow Beulah
she was beautiful
but that [ __ ] didn't have the GPS of a
box of rocks
three thousand slaves followed that
beautiful [ __ ] and wound up on their
same Masters Plantation at three in the
afternoon
[Applause]
damn it
[Music]
just gotta thank God for small blessings
I like all vaginas
but it's something about a big [ __ ]
ladies don't identify yourselves
I'm saying all glitter says are fine but
something about that big [ __ ]
fellas of you in here
with big [ __ ] I don't mean to be
disrespectful or nothing I'm not going
to refer to it as that anymore I'm gonna
say
faded the gentleman here with BC
now the fellas are here with big [ __ ]
don't raise your hands sir
said I raised my head
Bella you ever you ever seen a glitter
and so big you shame to your penis
you just called it at the wrong angle
you looked at that wrong did that [ __ ]
have a hook in it
some of the fellas looking at me because
you don't know if your girl's Glitters
Is
big or
too big
but that ain't true
cause your body will let you know if the
clitoris is too big
fellas you know your relationship with
the vagina is a dance
foreign
you feel your body doing something
that's unnatural
that's a red flag
so if you're eating the [ __ ] and you
feel yourself doing something you ain't
never done while eating [ __ ]
you feel yourself go
abort mission
[Applause]
they'll go
well you have had all the Glitters with
both your fingers
you catch yourself in the mirror
I am sucking this [ __ ] penis
in conclusion
laughs
it ain't nothing like that Big Clip
because that
I won't shout out
you hear that big glitches talk
they'll be they'd be all right for us
fellas when it first start but when it
don't stop growing we don't know what to
do so
you've been thinking of clearance that
is regular side
[Music]
swell up in your mouth
[Applause]